nous accueillons aujourd'hui elizabeth
moyrand gros magistrate secrétaire
général de l'ami prof
mission interministérielle pour la
protection des femmes contre les
violences et la lutte contre la traite
des êtres humains
bienvenue à vous madame elvire arrighi
commissaire divisionnaire chef de
l'office central pour la répression de
la traite des êtres humains à la
direction centrale de la police
judiciaire du ministère de l'intérieur
bienvenue monsieur jean baptiste baldo
commandant de police chef de pharos
à la sous direction de la lutte contre
la cybercriminalité du ministère de
l'intérieur bienvenue
et simon bernard courbon substitut du
procureur de la république qu référent
prostitution et traite des êtres humains
des mineurs à la division de la famille
et de la jeunesse du tribunal judiciaire
de bobigny bienvenus madame également je
vous souhaite à tous la bienvenue nous
avons trois principaux axes de travail
tout d'abord les conditions de
production de contenus pornographiques
les graves dérives dans le milieu
pornographique français relayés par la
presse nous ont amenés à nous interroger
sur les conditions dans lesquelles se
déroule le tournage je tiens à saluer le
travail d'investigation mené pendant
plus de deux ans par les enquêteurs de
la section de recherches de paris de la
gendarmerie nationale qui a permis de
recueillir les témoignages d'une
cinquantaine de victimes de pratiques de
recrutement sordide et de viols
agressions sexuelles et traite d'êtres
humains sous couvert de tournages
pornographiques
le traitement de ces affaires par la
gendarmerie nationale plutôt que par les
services de la police judiciaire est
semble-t-il lié à un concours de
circonstances et à l'implication et la
pugnacité des enquêteurs concernés une
instruction a été ouverte trois juges
d'instruction nommé et à ce jour nous
avons eu connaissance d'une douzaine de
mises en examen pour viol en réunion
traite aggravé d'êtres humains et
proxénétisme aggravé notamment ce type
d'affaires ne devrait-il toutefois part
élevée en principe de la compétence de
l'office central pour la répression de
la traite des êtres humains c'est une
question l'office ati déjà eu à traiter
de telles affaires par le passé et est
il appelé à le faire à l'avenir quel a
été son éventuelle implication
qu'elle a été
pardon quel a été son éventuelle
implication dans les affaires en cours
son expertise en matière de traite
d'êtres humains elle était sollicitée
tarn au delà des dérives révélée par la
presse nous nous interrogions plus
globalement sur les liens
qu'entretiennent proxénétisme
prostitution traite d'êtres humains et
pornographie la pornographie qui
implique des actes sexuels tarifés
peut-elle juridiquement être assimilé à
de la prostitution filmer cette activité
économique peut être relevée du chant
infractionnelle du proxénétisme dès lors
que l'on considère que la pornographie
est une forme d'exploitation sexuelle
nous souhaitons connaître votre analyse
en la matière notre deuxième axe de
réflexion concerne la nature des
contenus pornographiques
c'est contenu semble de plus en plus
extrêmes et dégradants est ce une vision
que vous partagez certaines vidéos sont
en outre manifestement illégal lorsqu
elles contiennent de la pédopornographie
des viols films et de l'incitation à la
haine ou d'autres contenus pénalement
réprimés comment les agents de pharos
traitent ils les signalements qui leur
sont faits de telle vidéo comment en
reçoivent t-il chaque mois et qu'elle
suit ils sont donnés
l'ami profs et l'office central pour la
répression de la traite des êtres
humains peuvent-ils également intervenir
mener des investigations ou saisir la
justice lorsque sont portés à leur
connaissance des vidéo filmant des
scènes de violences sexuelles ou
physiques de façon plus générale quels
échanges y at-il entre vos différents
services enfin notre troisième axe de
travail porte sur l'accès au contenu
pornographique qui s'est manifestée
depuis l'avènement des tubes ces
plateformes numériques proposant
gratuitement en un simple clic des
centaines de milliers de vidéos
pornographiques souvent piratées en
france les sites pornographiques affiche
une audience mensuelle d'environ 650
millions de visites dont 19 millions de
visiteurs uniques soit un tiers des
internautes
c'est en outre 80% des mineurs ont déjà
vu des contenus pornographiques et à 12
ans près d'un enfant sur trois a déjà
été exposée à de telles images nous nous
intéressons aux conséquences de cette
exposition précoce et notamment aux
liens qu'elle peut entretenir avec une
banalisation des rapports sexuels et
l'augmentation des conduites à risques
chez les adolescents notamment les
pratiques prostitutionnel récemment sont
apparus des plateformes telles que only
fans au mime qui permettent à des femmes
parfois très jeunes voire mineurs de
mettre directement en ligne du contenu
un caractère sexuel souvent filmées à
l'aide d'un smartphone est vendu
directement aux consommateurs à l'unité
ou contre un abonnement cette
pornographie à l'heure des circuits
courts ne s'apparentent elle pas
finalement à une activité
prostitutionnel monsieur bénard courbon
vous nous livrerait vos analyses sur ces
questions je laisse sans plus tarder la
parole elisabeth moir ombre aux
magistrates secrétaire général de l'ami
profs
et bienvenue à notre collègue rapporteur
laurence cohen qui me rejoint et les
autres
sénatrice rapporteur les membres de la
délégation sont connectés en visio et
salue la présence de bruno belin qui
avec nous si cet après midi à vous
madame elisabeth moins nombreux merci
merci beaucoup mesdames dessinatrice
chère laurence chars annick
de m'avoir invité donc à 7 à cette table
ronde enfin 7 août ses auditions sur la
pornographie
alors en ce qui concerne les questions
que vous avez pris je pense que je me
max plus sur la première c'est à dire
sur les liens qu'entretiennent
proxénétisme prostitution traite des
êtres humains et pornographie c'est sur
cette réponse je vais essayer de vous
aiguiller
et je voudrais juste faire une petite
précision germanique parce que vous avez
parlé de l'ami profs et
le crds est en disant est ce qu'on
pourrait pas mener des investigations
ensemble ou saisir la justice il faut
que je précise que l'ami prof est une
mission interministérielle pour apporter
son expérience et la lutte contre la
traite des êtres humains sur ce sujet là
elle est chargée de la coordination de
la lutte contre la traite des êtres
humains donc elle porte cette les chars
et de coordonner cette politique
publique mais nous ne sommes pas des
acteurs de terrain donc voilà ce sera
plutôt à elvire qui pourra répondre à
cette à cette question la question
n'était pas posée dans ce sens là bas on
en attendait c'est juste pour vous
préciser exactement ce que ce que nous
faisons
et voilà donc d'ailleurs je reviens de
de bruxelles où la réunion des
rapporteurs nationaux sur la lutte
contre la traite des êtres humains ce
qui nous a amenés à parler bien sûr de
l'exploitation sexuelle et bien sûr ça
vous étonnera pas si je vous dis que
nous n'avons pas prononcé le mot de
pornographie voilà donc c'est ça sera
nous prochaine je pense que prochaine
réflexion puisque elle sort en tout cas
enrichi par le rapport que vous allez
déposer sur ce point alors on a
l'habitude de le dire mais le
l'exploitation sexuelle est un marché
mondial un marché mondial qui rapporte
des profits criminels qui sont
extrêmement élevés puisque c'est la
troisième source de profits après le
trafic de drogue est presque à égalité
avec le trafic d'armes
mais c'est déjà un peu moins un premier
point par rapport aux docks la traite
des êtres humains c'est c'est quoi c'est
une infraction bien sûr et 7 cette
infraction elle vise plusieurs formes
d'exploitation ce que j'appelle
l'exploitation sexuelle elle couvre deux
sortes de termes qui sont dans l'article
225 4 1 ce sont les violences sexuelles
et le proxénétisme
donc moi je parle beaucoup
d'exploitations sexuelles on parle
beaucoup au sein de l'union européenne
au sein de l'onu de sexuel exploitation
mais il faut savoir que ça couvre plus
tôt en tout cas dans notre définition
juridique de notre pénal c'est le
proxénétisme on peut rapprocher aussi la
pornographie on parlera de aussi
exploiter quelqu'un à des fins et de
violences sexuelles on l'oubli parce
qu'on nous poursuit au poursuit très
rarement sur la trace de violence
sexuelle poursuit beaucoup de
proxénétisme on poursuit sur le travail
forcé bien sûr et puis tout le tout une
plusieurs plusieurs infractions
alors ce que je voudrais vous dire c'est
que effectivement au sein au niveau
international et au niveau européen
là la traite à des fins d'exploitation
sexuelle bien couvre bien entendu le la
prostitution lorsqu'on parle traite des
êtres humains exploitation sexuelle
consoeur que l'on soit dans les
instances internationales ou dans les
instances européennes ou encore chez
nous voilà on a tendance donc à penser
donc juste que c'est ça couvre la
prostitution d'ailleurs on appris
beaucoup au niveau de l'onu beaucoup de
conventions
internationales on ont porté sur ce
point notamment la la la convention de
1949 qui a fait un lien déjà direct
entre autres la prostitution et la
traite
et puis il ya eu aussi une autre
convention est venue plus tard que dans
60 ans je plonge et par là même à des
dates 79 sur l'élimination de toutes les
formes de discrimination à l'égard des
femmes qui condamne également la
prostitution et l'exploitation sexuelle
qui en est la suite parce qu'il faut
savoir que derrière la prostitution est
à 90% de personnes prostituées qui sont
victimes de traite des êtres humains
pour prendre un langage moins juridique
à des fins d'exploitation sexuelle
alors aujourd'hui donc on fait un
constat c'est que effectivement là la
pornographie n'est pas visé dans nos
textes dans les directives or ce qui
concerne la traite elle n'est pas
elle n'est pas visée non plus dans tout
ce que nous mettons en place au niveau
européen au niveau national mais
également au niveau national donc il n'y
a pas de rapprochement il ya très peu de
pays qui font un rapprochement sur ce
point sachant comme comme je voulais
dicté dans la définition pénale la paix
de la pornographie et même la pédo
pornographie n'est pas visés
expressément alors on peut ensuite
poursuivre sur d'autres chefs d'autres
chefs mais là on peut
alors
si la prostitution comme je voulais
dis-donc et est assimilé à la traite il
n'en est pas de même pour la
pornographie alors qu'en fait
si on réfléchit c'est de la pornographie
et la prostitution façon extrêmement
semblable en tout cas c c'est d'ailleurs
il a fallu que vous que vous commencez à
vous plonger sur le sujet pour que je me
dise c'est vrai qu'on aurait pu le
mettre dans les dents dans la directe
dans les directives ou en tout cas dans
les textes européens que nous avons trop
peu transposés pourquoi elles sont
semblables parce qu'on va parler de de
marchandisation des corps le corps est
un bien marchand
que ce soit pour que ce soit un adulte
un enfant
et est en fête et le but c'est
satisfaire je veux dire le plaisir
d'autrui alors la différence bien sûr
c'est que le plaisir d'autrui dans la
prostitution c'est le client et dans la
pornographie
bien c
c'est aussi les personnes qui prennent
du plaisir à regarder ces actes de
violence et les actes sexuels sera donc
finalement il n'y a pas une telle
différence si ce n'est que
effectivement dans notre droit on parle
peu on définit mal la prostitution
d'ailleurs est quant à elle et elle est
définie vaguement dans notre code c'est
dès que je me souvienne parce que j'ai
pas du tout de notes produit et on parle
de rapports physiques on parle de
rapports physiques donc on a
l'impression que là on s'éloigne un
petit peu mais en tout cas dans le cadre
du groupe de travail auquel j'ai
activement participé sur la prostitution
des mineurs il ya une des
recommandations qui était fait donc sous
la sous la houlette de la procureure
générale de la cour d'appel de paris
nous avons proposé une définition pour
justement parler de physique et virtuel
parce que maintenant nous sommes dans un
monde en pleine mutation et notamment
avec les révolutions technologiques etc
la prostitution se situe à ners
totalement totalement
différente voilà alors
ce que je voudrais vous dire c'est que
le rapprochement entre donc à partir de
ce constat là que finalement ça à peu
près les mêmes buts qui sont poursuivis
entre la prostitution et la pornographie
et bien on peut vraiment rapproché la
traite des êtres humains
parce que la définition de la traite
elle est large et elle couvre de
nombreuses situations
on recrute d'abord on recrute une
personne particulièrement vulnérable
en échange d'une rémunération ou d'un
autre d'un autre avantage en vue de
l'exploiter et sexuellement
donc on voit que l'on soit dans le cadre
de la prostitution on conçoit dans le
cadre de la pornographie eh bien on est
exactement rentre absolument dans ce
dans ce système là
parce que on le voit bien dans toutes
ces affaires qui ont émergé qui
d'ailleurs heureusement nous ont ouvert
les yeux sur la pornographie et et enfin
on en parle parce que c'était un sujet
un petit peu tabou quand même donc
maintenant on n'en pas vraiment et on
voit ce qu'il ya derrière
c'est
c'est sur des femmes qui sue qui sont
souvent qu'ils n'ont pas l'argent qui
sont qui sont mal qui s'est pas voilà
c'est pas n'importe qui qui qui va se
livrer à la la pornographie donc il ya
forcément il ya des facteurs de
vulnérabilité
c'est une évidence et puis on leur
propose une rémunération
donc à partir
à partir de là et aussi on peut mettre
la victime
enfin la traite d'êtres humains prévoit
que aussi c'est pour mettre la victime à
la disposition à sa disposition d'un
personnel ou encore à celle d'un tiers
afin de 2,2 de commettre des infractions
telles que proxénétisme l'agression des
atteintes sexuelles et d'autres encore
alors avec ce raisonnement là me suis
posé la question en préparant cette
cette audition
et surtout en le comparant avec les tous
les débats que nous avons eus pour la
loi de 2016
j'ai eu la chance leur souhaite le
rossignol n'est pas là mais lawrence
potvin été là nous avons été au bond du
parlement femmes ont en tout cas avec à
côté des mythes de la ministre des
ministres parce que plusieurs ministres
étaient tellement l'adopter voilà on se
retrouve toujours avec un débat qui est
le même au fond c'est est-ce que la
prostitution
est un acte
est-ce qu'il peut pas y avoir de la
prostitution qu'ils soient bien correct
voilà un appareil est ce qu a pas de la
pornographie qui peut tu peut se passer
très très bien et de prostitution où la
personne est d'accord ou voilà donc tout
ça c'était à mâcher abattu hier j'étais
à la commission européenne on a eu
encore entre entre états membres des
conseils des discussions extrêmement
vive l'ump très enrichissante sur ce
point là parce qu'on n'est pas de
beaucoup de pays européens sont pas
d'accord avec nous puisque nous nous
avons pris le parti d'interdire tout
achat d'acte sexuel
alors que beaucoup d'autres pays comme
l'allemagne l'autriche et cetera disent
que haut-fond si on encadre bien à la
prostitution pour être sûr que toutes
les personnes prostituées ne sont pas
des victimes de traite des êtres humains
ça va être formidable et que du coup ce
sera très bien le pourrons gagner leur
vie normale - tu sais c'est pas la
proche de la france on end approche
abolitionniste on l'assument et quand
même l'adoption de la loi de 2016 a fait
ses preuves la seule chose que je peux
regretter avec vous je vous le dis
franchement c'est que je trouve qu'elle
n'est pas suffisamment appliquée voilà
on est d'accord à
des vhu c'est pas un scoop bon et c'est
dommage parce que moi je me sers
beaucoup beaucoup de cet argument et
déception ça concerne aussi la
pédopornographie ce que je vais vous
dire que c'est très proche justement il
pour je pense qu'on peut les assimiler
c'est que moi je on se bat beaucoup au
sein de l'union européenne pour la
traite des êtres humains on sait que la
prévention de cette infraction c'est
extrêmement important et que la
prévention elle passe par décourager la
demande parce que comme c'est à marcher
à marcher c'est ça répond loi de l'offre
et de la demande et puis s'il n'y a pas
de demande débats il y aura moins
d'offres et puis et on arrivera à
éradiquer le phénomène bon il faut pas
rêver mais quand même où donc peu dire
que ça peut être dissuasif
voilà donc donc ça c'est c'est vraiment
très très très très important a souligné
et donc ça affaiblit ce que je veux dire
c'est que si on n'est pas vraiment très
vigilant sur justement ceux qui
utilisent sur l'interdiction d'acheter
un acte sexuel est là et là
et la sanction qui est derrière ça si on
n'applique pas bon ne sera pas bon là
sur ce point là bon c'est quand même
très très important de penser à ça la
réduction de la demande quoi que c'est
vraiment quelque chose il faut il faut
penser je pense que pour la
pédopornographie on peut penser
exactement pareil alors je me suis posé
la question en
référé en réfléchissant à tous les
thèmes que vous avez soulevé
donc moi je donc je vais vous dire je
conclus d'abord pour dire que la
prostitution et la pornographie sont à
rapprocher intimement voilà ce que je
pense
alors simplement où vais-je trouver le
client ou vais-je trouver l'auteur de
l'infraction
alors je me suis posé la question et du
coup je me suis dit que le projet le
producteur par exemple
et le proxénète
c'est une évidence puisque lui il va
tirer profit des actes sexuels que l'on
que l'on verra sur les films réalisés
ils ont tiré un profit très important
rentre dans la dimension très marchande
de 7,7 exploitations mais aussi
si si on examine bien façon si on
applique la loi de 2016 eh bien on peut
considérer que c'est également un client
puisque finalement
c'est lui qui va acheter quand même
l'acte sexuel pour le film et pas des
fins pour ce faire peut-être le plaisir
du film mais quoi qu'il arrive c'est
quand même lui qui l'achètent parce que
c'est lui qui va payer
alors ça c'est une première première
premier premier constat
donc
donc je voudrais donc revenir sur cette
histoire de marcher c'est l'industrie
pornographique
elle génère des profits absolument
considérable là aussi c'est un marché
qui est extrêmement lucratives comme
celui d'ailleurs de la prostitution pour
tout cas pour ceux qu'exploite
donc là donc comme je vous disais tout à
l'heure il faut faire en sorte qu'il n'y
ait plus de demandes mais ça c'est pas
dans ma sphère de compétence mais je
pense qu'il faut il faut vraiment faire
des campagnes de sensibilisation de
sueur sur ce sujet là il faut en parler
à l'école il faut et en parler à l'école
régulièrement vraiment je pense que
c'est un conflit de deux faces est
vraiment aujourd'hui c'est un
vraiment un problème de société vraiment
vraiment un problème de société et comme
tout bois pour vivre depuis longtemps au
milieu de tout ce contexte de
l'exploitation sexuelle etc et on
s'aperçoit que qu'il faut des affaires
graves comme celles qui a suscité toute
cette presse et caetera pour que tout à
coup les gens prennent conscience moi je
retour de mon père parlait jamais de la
pornographie depuis que qui a ces
affaires qui ont qui sont apparues on en
parle on en parle beaucoup et du coup ça
sensibilise sur ces six pas possible ça
se passe comme ça brille enfin parce que
et ça s'est passé dans des conditions
atroces donc c'est toujours il faut
toujours pied des événements comme ça
grave comme ça et c'est pour ça que je
trouve ça formidable vous avez tout de
suite vous voyez vous soyez vous ayez
pris ce sujet à bras le corps parce
qu'il faut le faire tant que le faire
échoue parce que aussi doit après ça se
déliter les gens là on n'y pense plus
c'est un petit peu un petit peu dommage
donc moi je trouve que clope quand je
leur parle de la prostitution ou que
l'on parle de la pornographie est bien
dans l'un ou l'autre cas l'être humain
considéré comme une marchandise c'est un
bien marchand absolument et que et que
et qu'on ne peut pas disposer d'accord
comme du marchandises voilà c'est aussi
simple que cela et en plus c'est
contraire à nos principes
constitutionnels notamment celui du
respect de la dignité humaine et je
voulais pas je vous en parle en
connaissance de cause je crois que c'est
un argument qui est très très important
celui là parce que malgré tout
quand quand on a débattu devant devant
le sénat et devant l'assemblée nationale
et bien c'est un argument que nous avons
soulevés vraiment beaucoup et qui avait
du mal être c'était du mal de le
combattre on avait du mal à combattre
parce que c'est quand même l'achat d'un
d'un du corps seulement c'est considérer
que lecointe a bien marché donc là juste
pour moi ça me paraît très important
tout cela est de dire que donc le
rapprochement de la pornographie avec la
traite des êtres humains elle est
absolument évident telle pose absolument
aucun problème je pense
elvire que toi tu parleras on parlera
bien sûr tu parleras de proxénétisme
plus mais ça ressemble on va reparler de
l'exploitation sexuelle donc ça ça ne
pose c'est vraiment je vois là je pense
qu'il y a tout ce qu'il faut d'ailleurs
cette affaire a été
poursuivi pour
aussi traite des êtres humains avec
circonstances aggravantes et
proxénétisme bien sûr avec circonstances
aggravantes qui sont quand même punir
très sévèrement donc
pas ce qu'on voit c'est pareil aussi
pour la constitution quand on me disait
ah oui mais il ya des personnes comme je
disais tout à l'heure pour ses passions
pour situer les elle veulent faire ça
pour leur propre plaisir mais je leur
dis aussi faut se mettre face à en
dehors de ce problème de la dignité
humaine il faut aussi avoir des
arguments concrets c'est à dire qu'est
ce qu'il ya dans la prostitution dans la
position il ya 90 % qui sont victimes de
traite des êtres humains derrière la
pornographie il ya forcément pour 80% 80
joueurs on n'a pas les chiffres mais je
pense à l'immense majorité parce que
j'ai pas les chiffres une immense
majorité qui sont victimes de
proxénétisme et de traite des êtres
humains donc à partir de lait fois de
pratiquer qu'est-ce qu'on fait parce que
ça c'est quand même des infractions qui
sont punis extrêmement sévèrement dans
notre de notre pénale parce que avant le
proxénétisme qui est plus pudique la
traite et je me sens très bien compris
pourquoi mais bon
peut-être que un jour c'est j'aurai la
réponse mais voilà donc ça je pense que
c'est vraiment important c'est s'est
laissé un petit peu ce que je voulais
partager avec vous c'est ce discours je
pense qui est là qui est donc le respect
de la dignité humaine et de dire que
derrière ce la pornographie il y a il y
a autre chose que peut être la colonne
des feux de l'amour quelqu'un qui va se
faire plein d'argent et ça va être
formidable
ils font plaisir aux gens qui sont ravis
de le faire donc c'est pas vrai c'est
pas ça la réalité c'est pas ça la
réalité elle est révélée par ces
affaires ce sont des violences c'est
forcément de l'exploitation parce que
dans la traite des êtres humains ont été
bien des promesses de faire des
promesses des offres de rémunération des
fausses promesses on a vu que tout le
fameux dossier était il n'y avait que
cela de fausses promesses des violences
sexuelles etc voilà donc ça vraiment ça
me paraît extrêmement important à
retenir et du coup je suis ravi d'avoir
une occasion de faire cette fois de
parler avec vous deux et d'échangé
aujourd'hui parce que on est en pleine
révision de la directive du 5 avril 2011
sur la traite des êtres humains et donc
moi je travaille beaucoup en ce moment
puisque la france est échu et puis je
suis rapporteur nationale et donc je
vais l'enlever j'ai vraiment envie de
proposer à ce que la pornographie soient
visés expressément dans la définition de
la traite d'êtres humains puisque nous
avons une définition au niveau
international et au niveau européen que
tous les pays tous les pays qui sont
obligés de prendre et que donc la
pornographie n'est pas n'est pas visé et
je pense que vraiment ce serait très
très bien qu'elle soit visée parce que
ça nous permettra en plus d'avoir une
meilleure approche n'approche plus plus
plus globale de dd des conditions
d'exploitation et des deux de ce que je
cache cette cette industrie qui la
posent donc la pornographie voilà
merci beaucoup madame elisabeth moyrand
bros pour ses propos extrêmement clair
et ses prises de position claire aussi
puisque vous avez à juste titre fait
vous êtes un certain nombre de questions
traite des êtres humains
prostitution pornographie
la loi sur l'abolition de la
prostitution avait mis quelques années à
être adoptés en réalité et les
réticences qu'il y avait eu adopter
cette loi finalement se démontre
aujourd'hui dans son application puisque
bien entendu nous avons au sein de la
délégation fait un travail sur le bilan
de l'application de cette loi elle est
extrêmement peu appliquée en réalité il
y a près de 400000 personnes prostituées
en france environ et il y à 1200
infractions constatées par an et ces
infractions sont essentiellement
constaté en région parisienne donc je
vous remercie pour les propos que vous
avez tenus parce que vous vous posez des
questions intéressantes à la fois sur la
prostitution c'est ce qu'on nous disait
à l'époque il pouvait y avoir une
prostitution éthique comme on nous dit
au cours de ces nombreuses auditions
n'est ce pas madame la rapporteur qui
pourrait y avoir une pornographie
éthique et une pornographie amateurs qui
ne seraient beaucoup moins éthique est
beaucoup moins respectueuses de la loi
donc c'est assez intéressant et lorsque
on parle de traite des êtres humains oui
c'est de l' achat d'acte sexuel donc le
la comparaison entre le producteur et le
proxénète n'avait pas encore été fait je
ne suis pas persuadé que ce sera au goût
de toutes les personnes que nous avons
pu auditionner jusqu'à l'or mais je vous
remercie pour la clarté de vos propos je
fais immédiatement passé la parole à
madame elvira righi comme madame la
commissaire divisionnaire et c'est à
vous la parole nous nous sommes compris
par le regard et le sourire
merci madame la présidente madame la
sénatrice messieurs les sénateurs
mesdames messieurs
créé en 1958 l'office central pour la
répression de la traite des êtres
humains que je dirige appartient à la
direction centrale de la police
judiciaire
dont le coeur de métier est la lutte
contre la criminalité organisée et le
grand banditisme
mon office dispose d'une compétence
nationale il se concentre sur la traite
des êtres humains à vocations sexuelle
et le proxénétisme
le proxénétisme
la mission de l'office est double elle a
d'abord un caractère opérationnel
il s'agit là de mener des enquêtes
complexes et élaboré afin de démanteler
des réseaux de traite des êtres humains
et de proxénétisme de grande envergure
pour cette mission opérationnelle mais
enquêteurs spécialisés utilise des
techniques spéciales denquête comme la
géolocalisation la pose de balises
l'enquète sous pseudonyme par exemple
dans le cadre d'investigations qui sont
longues et complexes
d'ampleur nationale ou internationale
bien sûr les services territoriaux de la
police judiciaire de la sécurité
publique et de la gendarmerie nationale
sont également compétent dans ce domaine
ils effectuent quant à eux
des enquêtes d'une ampleur et d'une
complexité moindre mais également
possiblement dans le domaine du
proxénétisme et de la traite des êtres
humains tout comme mon office
le deuxième volet de notre mission c'est
un volet stratégique
il s'agit là de concentrer pour le
ministère de l'intérieur l'intégralité
des données sur la thématique de la
traite à vocation sexuelle et du
proxénétisme
cela permet à mon office de disposer
d'une vision d'ensemble du phénomène de
son évolution et ça nous permet
également de détecter de nouvelles
tendances et d'en aviser les services
territoriaux afin que les méthodes d'
enquête s'adapte à ces changements
parfois rapides à
la traite et le proxénétisme est un
phénomène souvent supranationale le cred
travaille de concert avec ses homologues
d'autres pays
et avec des agences européennes et
internationales pour mettre en oeuvre et
bien des projets stratégiques de lutte
contre l'exploitation sexuelle
j'ai fait cette rapide présentation de
mon fils pour me permettre de vous
répondre à l'une de vos questions madame
à savoir évidemment en tant que chef de
file de la lutte contre la traite à
vocation sexuel qui est une mission qui
lui a été assignée par son arrêté de
création et une mission qui a été
réaffirmée à de nombreuses reprises dans
les doctrines gouvernementales notamment
récente
mon office doit à minima être avisés des
enquêtes menées par les services
territoriaux de police ou de gendarmerie
dans son domaine de compétences
et peut tout à fait se voir confier
l'anc est dès lors qu'elle a un
caractère particulièrement complexe au
vaste donc en l'occurrence nous n'avons
eu connaissance des deux enquêtes en
cours l'une à la section de recherche de
gendarmerie de versailles et l'autre 3e
district de police judiciaire de paris
que par voie de presse
alors par ailleurs vous me demandez
madame la présidente c'est l'office a
déjà eu à traiter de telles affaires par
le passé alors ce n'est pas du tout le
cas
toutefois il est bien évidemment arriver
que certaines victimes prostituées dans
les affaires de traiter de proxénétisme
que nous avons en portefeuille est été
par le passé actrice dans le domaine de
la pornographie
nous ne nous étions pas concertés madame
noir ont brouillé mois avant cette
intervention mais je pense qu'on est à
peu près tout à fait sur la même ligne
la porosité entre le monde de la
prostitution est celui de la
pornographie est évidente
vous l'avez largement d'ailleurs évoqué
dans les travaux de votre table ronde
dont j'ai pris connaissance
j'ajouterai simplement que mes
enquêteurs dans leur travail quotidien
sur internet pour démanteler des réseaux
de proxénétisme
tombe très régulièrement sur des
annonces vantant l'expérience
le domaine de la pornographie des
prostituées
il ya un acronyme bien connue de mes
enquêteurs qui s'appelle pse 1 point
d'orgue expérience donc ça veut tout
dire donc l'intersection est absolument
incontestable celles qui sont exploités
dans le domaine de la prostitution le
sont également régulièrement dans le
cadre de la pornographie
la dernière question qui s'adressent à
nous mènera un développement plus plus
long puisque vous me demandez enfin
madame la présidente si l'office est
appelé à traiter de telles affaires à
l'avenir
alors bien entendu mon office mènera
toute enquête de traite à vocation
sexuelle ou de proxénétisme qui lui sera
confiée par la justice
je rappelle cependant que la mission de
police judiciaire tel que défini dans le
code pénal et celle de constater les
infractions à la loi pénale d'en
rassembler les preuves et d'en
rechercher les auteurs
une enquête de mon office et donc
nécessairement est évidemment
conditionnée à l'existence même d'une
infraction
donc dès lors il convient de
s'interroger pour répondre à votre
question sur l'applicabilité des
infractions de proxénétisme et de traite
des êtres humains à l'encontre de
l'industrie pornographique
alors pour pour éclairer ce sujet
j'écarte tout de suite de mon propos la
pédopornographie pour laquelle
l'illégalité n'est absolument pas
débattu de
la même manière il convient d'exclure de
notre réflexion les situations évoquées
précédemment par madame moiron bros de
violence extrême de tromperie quant à la
nature des actes sexuels a réalisé deux
contraintes physiques et de viol
collectif dans le contexte de tournages
pornographiques puisque de ces
situations absolument dramatique découle
de manière claire et incontestable des
responsabilités pénales pouvant être
qualifiés de différentes manières et
notamment de traite des êtres humains
donc sur ces sujets là il ya peu ou pas
de débat la réflexion est évidemment
bien plus complexe s'agissant de
l'industrie pornographique au sens large
en général
quand elles se déroulent disons de
manière classique alors quel parallèle
juridique peut-on établir avec le
proxénétisme et la traite à vocation
sexuelle
pour un juriste est madame moyrand brawl
à la rappeler à l'instant les deux
situations font appel aux notions de
respect fondamental de la dignité
humaine qui peut être bafouée par
l'exploitation sexuelle et la
marchandisation du corps
l'exploitation sexuelle actuellement
réprimées dans le code pénal par les
infractions de traite et de proxénétisme
vistelle uniquement des situations de
prostitution au sens traditionnel si
j'ose dire du terme ou vistelle
également des situations de pornographie
alors penchons nous d'abord sur la
notion de consentement commercial
et là forcément je vais me servir de ce
que j'ai l'habitude de voir dans les
dossiers que traitement d'office
c'est-à-dire la situation les situations
de prostitution au sens classique
dans ces situations là exactement comme
dans la pornographie il est difficile
d'imaginer que les actes de pornographie
même consentie ne découle pas d'une
nécessité matérielle et d'une précarité
économique dont souffre ce qui s'y livre
plutôt que d'un choix libre et éclairé
l'existence du consentement de la
personne qui se livre à des actes
sexuels empêche-t-il le matérialiser des
infractions de proxénétisme de traite
dans le cas de prostitution au sens
classique du terme telle que nous la
voyons dans nos dossiers à l'office il
est clair que non
l'esprit de la loi de 2016 et de tous
les textes internationaux que la france
a signé à ce sujet repose sur l'idée que
les victimes doivent être protégés
contre leur propre consentement et que
la contrainte n'a pas besoin d'être
présente pour caractériser l'infraction
la grande majorité des victimes
prostituées que nous entendons dans nos
enquêtes suite à l'interpellation de
leurs proxénètes
affirme cette prostituée de leur plein
gré il s'agit même souvent d'un quasi
accord commercial un peu comme dans la
pornographie
entre la victime et son exploitant avec
lequel elle partage les gains et qui
assure la logistique de la prostitution
dans nos dossiers on a même parfois à
faire à de véritables petites
entreprises de prostitution on voit les
missions de recrutement de comptabilité
de gestion du standard etc il y a donc
une entente cordiale entre le proxénète
et sa victime prostituer pour antant la
fraction est tout à fait caractérisée et
les victimes sont reconnus dans leurs
statuts et dans les droits qui en
découlent
donc c'est bien l'esprit de notre droit
déjà tels qu'ils existent que de dire
même si l'intérêt économique et partager
on ne peut infliger cela à personne et
personne ne doit profiter matérialisme
profiter matériellement paraderont des
services sexuels tarifés d'un tiers
la notion de dignité humaine est
objective et elle supplante dans notre
doigt droit celle du consentement elle
subjective et donc forcément sujettes à
manipulation
dès lors la question que nous devons
nous poser dans le cas de la
pornographie n'est pas s'agit-il d'un
accord commercial car aucun contrat ne
peut être fait au sujet d'une activité
illégale
le droit pénal primant ainsi peu importe
le consentement des actrices dans le
domaine de la pornographie
peu importe des contrats signés là n'est
pas le sujet
le consentement nous permet de
distinguer un viol d'un acte sexuel
consenti
le consentement ne nous permet en rien
de distinguer le proxénétisme de
l'industrie pornographique
donc une fois écartées la problématique
du consentement demeure
la dernière problématique et pas des
moindres à savoir la définition de la
prostitution
puisqu'en effet il est quand même
essentiel de rappeler que l'infraction
de proxénétisme en france
qui est l'article 225 tiré 5 du code
pénal présuppose sans la définir
l'existence de prostitution
de manière condensée le code pénal dit
que le proxénétisme et le fait d'aider
six thés ou de protéger la prostitution
d'autrui de tirer profit de la
prostitution d'autrui
alors on pourrait se dire bon si le
proxénétisme ne fonctionne pas on peut
regarder du côté de la traite mais en
fait on a le même problème avec la
traite puisque la traite
des êtres humains à vocations sexuels
qui allait donc l'article 225-1 4-1 du
code pénal repose elle sur l'existence
du proxénétisme donc par ricochet delà
de la prostitution
donc on doit vraiment se poser la
question
est ce que pornographie égale
prostitution voilà c'est la seule
question que nous devons nous poser
la répression du proxénétisme est
particulière puisque on poursuit une
activité par référence à une autre
activité la prostitution qui elle même
n'est ni défini ni réprimée par la loi
et c'est toujours sur la prostitution
que se focalise la traite des êtres
humains or le champ du trafic sexuel est
plus vaste
profiter économiquement de la
prostitution d'un tiers tombe
immanquablement sous le coup de la loi
pénale et dès lors la question que nous
devons nous poser et la pornographie
peut-elle être qualifié de prostitution
alors en l'absence de définition légale
eh bien il convient de se tourner vers
la jurisprudence en l'occurrence celle
de la chambre criminelle de la cour de
cassation du 27 mars 1996
que je vais citer alors cette
jurisprudence elle dit la prostitution
consiste à se prêter moyennant une
rémunération à des contacts physiques de
quelque nature qu'ils soient afin de
satisfaire les besoins sexuels d'autrui
le récent phénomène des call girls ce
qu'ils sont des shows érotiques via
webcam souvent rémunérés ne peut
absolument pas satisfaire aux exigences
de cette jurisprudence les victimes
étant pour la majeure partie seuls face
à leur écran bien qu rémunéré par le
spectateur et donc il n'y a pas on ne
retrouve pas pour les call girls ce
qu'on a dans cette définition
jurisprudentielle à savoir le fameux
contact physique
c'est pour ça d'ailleurs que il y a eu
en 2021 la création d'une infraction
spécifique pour couvrir ce type de
situation quand il touche des victimes
mineures
mais le cas de la pornographie est bien
différent me semble-t-il puisque il ya
effectivement en contact sexuel
matériel entre au moins deux personnes
filmées
cet acte est rémunéré
donc s'agit-il de prostitution
il me semble que les trois critères de
la jurisprudence de 1996 sont
possiblement rempli par là par la
pornographie à savoir l'activité
satisfait le besoin sexuel d'autrui
premièrement deuxièmement implique une
rémunération troisièmement relève de
contact physique
alors il faut apporter un bémol à cette
analyse parce que ce qui différencie la
pornographie de la prostitution au sens
traditionnel du terme qui était
d'ailleurs sens traditionnel qui était
d'ailleurs en espèces visées par la
jurisprudence de 96 de la cour de
cassation c'est que dans le cas de la
perte de la pornographie la personne qui
rémunère n'est pas celle qui profite de
l'acte sexuel
ni physiquement ni d'ailleurs derrière
son écran
donc celui qui rémunère n'est pas le
client entre guillemets il est le
producteur et ils en tirent un bénéfice
uniquement financier et non pas lié aux
services sexuels
dans la prostitution traditionnel on a
affaire à un trio et ce trio on va
l'appeler pour se comprendre entre nous
victimes clients proxénète donc l'argent
est donné par le client à la victime qui
en reverse une part aux proxénètes ça
c'est ce qu'on a nous traditionnellement
dans nos dossiers
dans la pornographie on a également un
trio
il est cette fois le trio victime
spectateurs qui peut être assimilé aux
clients et producteurs qui peut être
assimilé aux proxénètes donc dans cette
situation de pornographie ce n'est pas
le spectateur ce n'est pas le client qui
rémunère la victime
c'est le producteur le proxénète qui lui
même reçoit l'argent généré par la liste
bution du film ou des images donc le
circuit financier et distant
et au delà du circuit financier on a une
autre distinction c'est la nature de
l'acte commise par le client
la relation sexuelle matériel d'au moins
deux individus telle qu'elle est visée
par là par la jurisprudence
existe bien contrairement à la situation
précédemment évoqué des call girls mel
axe l'acte sexuel physique n'est pas
réalisée par le client qui lui est
derrière son écran
tout comme dans le cas des call girls
donc au total le consommateur de plaisir
si j'ose dire ne rémunère pas et il ne
profite pas d'un contact réel et
physique avec la personne rémunérée et
ces deux éléments diffère de la
situation traditionnel traditionnel de
la prostitution
il revient donc soit au législateur de
définir la prostitution et de dire si
elle couvre également ces cas
si le législateur dit que la
prostitution couvre également ces cas
alors le proxénétisme et la traite à
vocation sexuels seront systématiquement
caractérisée dans le cas de production
pornographique
le législateur peut le faire au niveau
national il peut le faire au niveau
européen
soit le législateur le fait soi c'est la
jurisprudence qui tranche dans un cas
d'espèce qui concerne effectivement la
pornographie ce qui n'est pas le cas de
duca de 1996
je rappelle d'ailleurs comme l'a fait
madame moins nombreux tout à l'heure que
le rapport du groupe de travail sur la
prostitution des mineurs rendus en juin
2021 à monsieur adrien taquet
recommandait déjà l'introduction dans le
code pénal d'une définition légale de la
prostitution
mon office avait largement contribué à
ce groupe de travail qui avait proposé
la définition suivante
la prostitution consiste à se prêter
contre rémunération ou avantages en
nature ou la promesse de l'un d'eux à de
relations sexuelles physiques ou
virtuels pour moi cette proposition de
texte couvre les situations de
pornographie
pour conclure il n'appartient pas à la
police judiciaire de se prononcer d'un
point de vue éthique ou morale sur la
nécessité d'appliquer les infractions de
proxénétisme et de traite à vocation
sexuelle à l'industrie pornographique
il est en revanche de notre devoir
d'appliquer la loi et toute la loi en
l'absence regrettable de définition de
la prostitution dans le code pénal c'est
aux magistrats que revient la
responsabilité de considérer ou non que
les acteurs et actrices du milieu
pornographique sont en situation de
prostitution
et qu'il s'agit donc de victime de
proxénétisme
et ou de traite des êtres humains
voilà donc une question de politique
pénale tant pour la mise en branle de
l'action publique ouvre ton une enquête
pour proxénétisme ou pour traite à
vocation sexuelle les poursuites pénales
sont elles possibles
que pour la jurisprudence au moment du
jugement la fraction est elle
caractérisée
ainsi donc la balle n'est t'elle pas
dans le camp de la police nationale mais
plutôt dans celle du législateur et de
la justice
je vous remercie pour votre attention
merci beaucoup madame elvire arrêt qui
pour ces propos qui complète à juste
titre les propos de madame elisabeth
moiron bros vous avez mis le doigt en
réalité sur un certain nombre de
questions que la délégation et les
rapporteurs se pose avec moi depuis le
début de ses auditions en janvier avec
la notion de consentement la notion d'
achat d'acte sexuel et vos rapprochement
ou vos parallèle que vous avez pu faire
avec la prostitution la pornographie
était extrêmement intéressant est
éloquent c'est à dire que on a très vite
compris que il ya des questions qui se
posent il ya des choses à faire et
lorsque nous avons décidé de travailler
ce sujet avec les rapporteurs en début
d'année nous avions pris connaissance
avec la procureure chant renault du
travail qui avait été menée pour la
prostitution des mineurs et donc c'est
quelque chose dont on a pris
connaissance et qui va ces man alimenté
aussi notre réflexion je vais merci donc
pour cette intervention tout à fait
éclairante avec des pistes vous avez
renvoyé la balle gentiment je vous
remercie et nous allons poursuivre avec
monsieur jean baptiste
baldo donc qui dirige la plateforme
pharos et c'est à vous monsieur
merci madame la présidente
alors la plateforme pharos
c'est une plateforme comme son nom
l'indiqué de signalements et non pas une
plate forme de plainte
puisque faro signifie plateforme
d'harmonisation d'analysé de recoupement
et d'orientation des signalements et a
été voulu comme tel
de sorte que tout à chacun et pas
nécessairement la victime d'un fait peut
porter à fait licite à notre
connaissance
pharos existe depuis 2009 et
dès sa genèse été orientés vers la
pornographie mais pédopornographie
puisque le frotte au pharos qui existait
de 2006 à 2008
est
exclusivement orienté pédopornographie à
partir de 2009 lorsque la plateforme
publique a été mise au jour
a été livré
nous nous sommes intéressés à tout
contenu illicite
absolument tout contenu
de sorte que tout à chacun peut signaler
à pharos
l'illicéité d'un contenu en ligne à
condition bien sûr qu'ils soient publics
de sorte que les internautes
particuliers les associations
les administrations et même les acteurs
de l'internet peuvent porter à notre
connaissance des signalements je vous
expliquerai par la suite qu'elle est
puisque c'était votre question madame la
présidente
le la manière dont nous les traitons
pharos est désormais à la faveur d'un
vent fort l'année dernière plus de 50
agents policiers des gendarmes qui
fonctionne h 24 7 24 heures sur 24 7
jours sur 7 et nous avons trois axes
majeurs de travail le traitement des
signalements que j'ai tendance à appeler
le gros-oeuvre puisque pour vous donner
un exemple
l'année dernière nous avons traité
toutes catégories confondues 300 soit
365 milles signalement parce que les
usages de l'internet en allant qu'en
s'accroissant le nombre de signalements
que nous recevons à l'heure actuelle et
croît de manière si j'ose dire
exponentielle nous en avions reçu à peu
près 50 mille l'année de notre naissance
en 2009
donc comme je vous le disais c'est le
gros de notre travail nous avons des
équipes étoffées pour tresser pour
traiter ces signalements étant précisé
que tout signalement est instruit aucun
est mis de côté
et nous devons pour tous lui trouver une
issue il en est que nous classons parce
qu'il n'est pas nécessairement motif ou
le moyen d'en faire quelque chose mais
notre philosophie notre raison d'être
c'est d'orienter les signalements
c'est à dire de les envoyer à des
services de police territorialement
compétent ou des services centraux nous
travaillons avec tous les services de
police et de gendarmerie bien sûr de
france centraux ou territoriaux et nous
avons d'ailleurs à cette occasion
de nombreuses reprises envoyer des
signalements alors à l'office que dirige
mme à dammarie
nous avons un pôle judiciaire qui va
lorsqu un signalement nécessite que on
identifie l'internaute qui se cache
derrière un pseudonyme qui a pu
s'adonner mise et nous allons prendre
les premiers accidents ont comme est lé
premier acte au lac denquête ouvrir un
dossier chaque fois que nécessaire et
ensuite adressé ce dossier après
l'identification de l'auteur à un
service de police
une fois encore ou de gendarmerie
territorialement compétent ou un service
central est la particularité de pharos
par rapport à d'autres plateformes
similaires ailleurs dans le monde c'est
que nous avons un pouvoir de police
administrative
et là en matière de pédopornographie
ou de d'apologie du terrorisme aux
provocations à commettre des actes de
terrorisme
nous pouvons exercer un pouvoir
d'injonction et demandé le retrait la
suppression pure et simple des contenus
à l'éditeur ou l'hébergeur si celui-ci
ne
ne diffère pas notre demande nous
pouvons à ce moment-là bloquer les
contenus c'est à dire en fait obtenir la
déviation des requêtes vers une page du
ministère de l'intérieur et ou
[Musique]
demander un déréférencement c'est à dire
une suppression des contenus des moteurs
de recherche
en matière de pédopornographie en pl en
matière de blocage pardon c'est à dire
le détournement des requêtes l'année
écoulée les mesures que nous avons
prises ont permis d'empêcher
environ quasiment 3 millions 500 mille
consultations et 90 % concernaient la
pédopornographie
alors vous me demandiez la présidente si
je pouvais fournir des chiffres en
matière de pornographie je ne le
pourrait pas sauf en matière de
pédopornographie
parce que pour eux la pornographie dans
notre base n'est pas une rubrique en
tant que tel je peux vous dire en
revanche en matière de pédopornographie
que le mois dernier nous avons traité
1970 signalements concernant les
atteintes aux mineurs ce qui sur
l'ensemble de l'année écoulée porte le
nombre de signalements relatifs à des
atteintes aux mineurs à plus de 8200
comment est traitée me demandez vous
madame la présidente
un signalement alors en fait
l'internaute va sur notre portail
d'accueil
et nous indique le lien l'url d'un
contenu qui mène à un contenu illicite
il ne peut pas pour ce qui le concerne
déposé deux pièces jointes pour des
questions de sécurité informatique donc
ce sont nos agents puisque nous avons
des équipes qui travaillent
h24 dizaine de jour comme de nuit sur
différents régimes de travail et qui
traite les cinémas en temps réel c'est à
dire qu'un signalement lorsqu'il arrive
il est hiérarchisé en fonction de sa
gravité
mais il est pris en compte dans les
minutes qui suivent ce sont des pots
donc les agents vont récupérer l'url du
contenu incriminé allait mener des
constatations et ce qualité de policier
ou gendarme prendre toutes mesures
conservatoires nécessaires c'est-à-dire
capture enregistrement
enrichir cette
cette démarche d'une recherche en base
pour voir si le contenu nous est déjà
été dénoncé auquel cas on peut avoir un
signalement qui va décidément qui sont
rattachés les uns aux autres quand il
concerne le même contenu et puis mené
des recherches complémentaires en source
ouverte chaque fois que de besoin
nous allons par la suite trouvé si cela
est possible puisque nous sommes tenus
par l'état de droit une qualification et
nous orienterons nous orienterons comme
je vous le disais tout à l'heure soit
faire un service
police ou gendarmerie centrale ou
territoriale je communiquerai quelques
chiffres en matière de proxénétisme
soit nous commençons les premiers actes
visant à identifier l'auteur avant de
réorienter
donc en matière de proxénétisme pour
l'année écoulée nous avons cent quarante
et un signalement et nous les avons
transmis nous en avons transmis de 83
cents procédure c'est à dire que le
contenu était directement exploitables
et nous avons fait parvenir cesser ces
signalements à lauprêtre idem en matière
de tva je suis signalement 6e transmis
un lot crète et en matière de racolage
62 signalements dont 12 transmis à la
crête
relativement à
l'amplitude l'ampleur de notre de notre
tâche puisque je le rappelle on a brassé
l'année dernière soit 165 signalement le
sujet est relativement circonscrites
en revanche en matière de paix et de
diffusion d'imagés à caractère
pédopornographique
c'est 5 plus de 500 enquêtes que nous
avons diligenté par nouveau groupe par
nous mêmes
c'est vrai que la pédopornographie est
un sujet qui nous préoccupe
particulièrement les domaines trad dn
depuis le début de l'existence de pharos
nous sommes tenus comme je le disais
comme l'a fort bien expliqué marc egly
parle par l'état de droit
mais chaque fois que nous aurons nous
sommes confrontés à une
un contenu illicite nous posons nous
prenons les mesures nécessaires mais
j'insiste sur le fait que nous n'avons
pouvoirs de police administrative en
revanche qu'en matière de
pédopornographie de terrorisme pour le
reste des contenus licites qui pourrait
être trouvé sur sur internet de quelque
nature qu'il soit nous allons invoqué
l'article 6 de la loi de la confiance
dans l'économie numérique et nous
devenons auprès d'édith héros de
l'hébergeur
signalant un autre tour et nous le
mettons demeure enfin nous le réclamons
s'ils hébergent un contenu illicite de
l'hôte et de le retirer mais nous
n'avons plus dans ce cas or là nous
n'avons pas de pouvoir d'injonction donc
l'éditeur ou l'hébergeur défaire à notre
demande ou pas et
autant en matière de pédopornographie et
de terrorisme nous annonce pour
atteindre fonctions et l'éditeur ou
l'hébergeur qui ne dessert pas
risque d'engager sa responsabilité
pénale là dans le cas présent
nous ne sommes pas sur le même portage
voilà ce que je pouvais vous dire sur
les sur l'intervention des personnels de
pharos
merci beaucoup monsieur baldo pour cette
intervention sur la plateforme pharos
qui est un élément essentiel du
dispositif pour lutter contre la
criminalité sur la toile donc merci à
vous pour cette intervention je vais je
vais céder la parole aux derniers
intervenants monsieur simon bénard
courbon et c'est à vous les parents la
parole pour clôturer ce tour de table
est ensuite bien entendu je passerai
pour qu'ils se préparent la parole au
sénateur rapporteur soit en salle soit
en visioconférence qui le souhaitent
pour poser des questions j'en merci à
vous monsieur
présidente madame la présidente madame
et messieurs et mesdames les rapporteurs
madame mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs dont je vous remercie tout
d'abord votre invitation cette table
ronde portant sur la pornographie et je
tiens également à remercier les services
du sénat pour leur disponibilité dans la
préparation de cette intervention
permettez moi de me présenter très
rapidement sur 20 pouces et celle sur
mon activité au quotidien où je suis
magistrat judici un substitut du
procureur de la république au sein du
parquet des mineurs du sauna judiciaire
de bobigny c'est le deuxième tribunal de
france en terme d'activité et des
effectifs de magistrats et de
fonctionnaires donc au quotidien en tant
que substitut du parquet au parquet des
mineurs je traite principalement des
affaires de délinquance la mettant en
cause des mineurs d'une part et d'autre
part je traite d'infraction violentes ou
sexuels commis sur des victimes mineures
des xix mineurs comme le proxénétisme
notamment depuis bientôt quatre ans que
je suis référent en matière de
prostitution et le traite des êtres
humains sur les victimes mineures vous
donner une ampleur du phénomène dans
notre dans notre tribunal et sur leur
sort la seine-saint-denis ce sont deux
mineurs qui sont signalés par semaine
comme étant en situation de prostitution
avérée ou pour lesquels il ya des doutes
donc deux mineurs par semaine ça chaque
fois de nouvelles la situation on est à
2 puis 2019 à environ cent vingt 120
situation par an ce qui est un chiffre
très important
s'agissant d'un chiffre révélé la
justice et la police ne connaissent ne
connaissent qu'une partie de la
délinquance le chiffre noir étant bien
plus important mon intervention
s'articulera autour de deux axes le
premier c'est de savoir quels sont les
liens qu'il est possible de faire entrer
la pornographie et la prostitution des
mineurs ça a déjà été fait de manière
très précise a précédemment moi je me
concentre sur des considérations plutôt
sociologique et le second axe de mon
intervention portera sur la question que
vous m'avez posé madame la présidente à
savoir si l'exposition sexuelle des
mineurs en ligne compte contre une
rémunération peut s'apparenter à une
activité prostitutionnel dans un premier
temps qu'elle quels sont les liens
possibles entre la pornographie et la
prostitution des mineurs je vais évoquer
du coup bas les causes d'entrer dans la
prostitution de mineure mais elles sont
nombreuses
vous l'imaginez bien dans le cadre de
mon de ma référence j'ai été amené à
travailler également dans le cadre du
groupe de travail qui a été évoqué par
par les intervenants précédents et
une des causes principales vous le savez
c'est des violences sexuelles physiques
ou psychiques quelle qu'elle soit c'est
l'une des causes principales qui amène à
leur entrée dans la prostitution mais ce
n'est pas la seule bien évidemment il y
en a
il y en a d'autres puisque on parle
traite de manière très classique de
l'expansion du phénomène de la pression
du mineur depuis une dizaine d'années
environ
au début des années
2010 parce que la prostitution des
mineurs n'est pas nouvelle depuis de
très nombreuses années j'ai pas envie de
dire de tout temps mais depuis très
nombreuses années la prostitution des
mineurs et
existe un les chiffres en la matière
sont constants on sait qu un mineur
entre dans la prostitution en général
autour de 14 ans est habituellement les
lieux de rencontre des proxénètes et des
démineurs prostituées sont les garants
classiquement lui de fugue aujourd'hui
c'est internet qui feront
le deuxième la deuxième cause d'entrée
qui m'apparaît important de souligner
sur la l'entrée dans la prostitution
c'est lié à la banalisation de l'acte
sexuel résultant des nouvelles
technologies de communication et donc là
je suis en lien cas le thème de la
pornographie
puisque la pornographie en ligne prend
également son ampleur à la même peu près
la même période que la procession du
mineur prend son envol c'est à dire
début de l'année 2010 et pour
différentes raisons techniques que vous
connaissez d'une part vous avez l'essor
des smartphones et ses smartphones sont
non seulement utilisé par les adultes
mais aussi par les affres les enfants
les adolescents aujourd'hui un de
manière si on parle en termes de
génération vous avez en général les
jeunes qui sont dans les années 2000 ont
quasiment tous un téléphone portable et
un smartphone à l'âge de l'adolescence
ou la pré adolescence se porte à ce
téléphone portable permet lui-même
l'accès à des sites internet
pornographiques puisque les systèmes de
contrôles parentaux vous le savez ont
une efficacité relative en la matière
vous allez donc plusieurs générations
depuis les années 2000 deux garçons et
deux filles qui ont un accès facilité à
la pornographie dans leur poche de
pantalon dans la cour de récréation cet
accès facilité doit être mis en
opposition à des générations précédentes
dont la mienne qui n'avaient pas qui n'a
laissé que de manière restreinte à la
pornographie via des revues des livres
des vhs ou des cinémas se dédier voir à
l'époque où c'était pour est prohibé
donc voyez bien qu'il ya un décalage
énorme entre ce que les générations
actuelles connaissent et les générations
présentes ont pu connaître en matière
d'accès à la pornographie vous évoquez
dans votre introduction un chiffre très
éloquent s'agissant de l'accès à la
pornographie en ligne par la mineure cet
accès facilité à la pornographie a
nécessairement un acte sur l'a1
nécessairement un effet de banalisation
sur l'acte sexuel
j'en veux pour jean veut deux exemples
issus de la pratique judiciaire c'est
celui de la fellation qui est devenu un
acte extrêmement anodin pour la plupart
des adolescents s'est en effet quelque
chose que mes collègues et moi-même
constate au quotidien dans nos affaires
qu'on traite en matière d'agression
sexuelle et de viol la fellation est
devenu quelque chose de très banal
alors que ça ne l'est pas est une autre
affaire pour le coup bien plus sordide
eu qu'une simple fellation
malheureusement c'est une affaire de
proxénétisme qui mettait en cause un
adolescent qui a prostituée pendant
plusieurs semaines une jeune fille
adolescente également et dans cette
affaire on a des échanges de sms entre
ce proxénète et cette jeune fille ou le
jeune homme lui dit qu'il a trouvé un
client qui intéressait pour une
prestation sexuelle donc rémunérés
impliquant plusieurs milliers d'euros 1
est la raison de cette importance de
rémunération c'est parce qu'elle a une
dimension scatologique la jeune fille de
lui répondre par sms donc ça tu as
changé très cru qu'elle veut pas
vraiment le faire ça que c'est trop
violent ça intéresse pas et le jeune
homme qui va lui répondre tout
simplement tu prendras une douche après
tout ça pour vous montrer à quel point
les actes sexuels sont devenus eux mêmes
les plus extrêmes les plus dégradants
sont devenues d'une simplicité extrême
pour pour ces jeunes qui ont accès à la
pornographie d'ondés la pornographie
scatologique
deuxième troisième élément qui fin ce
qui est en lien avec ce que je viens de
dire c'est la question de la
marchandisation des corps qu'on a évoqué
et des échanges sexuels dans la culture
médiatique auquel les adolescents ont
taxé à nouveau ça a du sens à et du lien
avec l'activité judiciaire donc d'une
part dans les films pornographiques on
l'a rappelé un et vous avez entendu
de mémoire madame gl maîtresse de
conférences qui a travaillé cette
question déjà des adolescents et de
l'accès aux films pornographiques et
c'est très en lien avec la réalité que
je connais de mes dossiers puisque vous
avez des jeunes qui ont accès à ces
contenus pornographiques qui présente
les femmes de manière comme des objets
sexuels à la disposition des hommes
elles sont très souvent violentes et
dans ces images sont soumises à ces
derniers ces images associées à penser
aux jeunes que je coupe que je rencontre
dans les dossiers judiciaires que ce
sont les rapports sexuels qui sont
visionnées sur la norme la norme
sexuelle et
on peut s'interroger assez légitimement
sur le fait que ces jeunes qui
visionnent les garçons en particulier
mais aussi des filles les garçons qui
vient de ses films pornographiques à un
âge où ils sont en état de leurs de
construction il se socialise ses films
vont influer sur leur façon d'être
d'avoir le rapport aux femmes en général
ou dans leur vie sexuelle et notamment
faciliter la rentrée leur entente
clients ou en tant que proxénète c'est
notamment ce que j'ai pu comprendre
lorsque dont il ya des interventions de
sensibilisation dans les établissements
scolaires ou lorsqu'on parle de
prostitution avec des jeunes très
souvent vous allez voir des garçons qui
n'ont aucune conscience de ce qu'est le
consentement encore aujourd'hui
donc la question de savoir si dans les
pros sûr que je traite à l'idée que la
mineurs exploités n'est qu'un objet
c'est vraiment une constante il arrive
parfois proxénète de vendre les jeunes
filles donc ça montre bien que ce sont
des objets pour quelques centaines
d'euros de les échanger lorsqu'il trouve
laisser jeune fille trop pénible ou trop
peu rentable financièrement et très
souvent ce qu'on retrouve dans nos
dossiers judiciaires de proxénétisme ils
vont les brutaliser physiquement parfois
à l'extrême avec des risques de
séquelles physiques irrémédiable mais
pour les proxénètes la jeune fille qui
les exploitent un effectivement qu'une
marchandise interchangeables ainsi les
inventions c'est un lien certain entre
la pornographie et l'essor du
proxénétisme sur les mineurs en raison
de l'utilisation massive des smartphones
j'ai vu jouer de d'évoquer l'accès
internet haut débit de l'accès facile
facilité qui permet que permet la
pornographie par les enfants et qu'il
devienne éventuellement des clients des
proxénètes autre point sur les 7
questions de la marchandisation des
corps
qui a peut-être été évoquée mais je ne
suis pas certain par d'autres
intervenants au préalable c'est la
question des émissions de téléréalité en
lien avec les images en lien avec
l'image de la femme véhiculée par les
films pornographiques se pose à mon avis
la question de savoir si la femme le
l'image de la femme véhiculée par les
émissions de télé réalité comme elles
sont nombreuses gens si quelques-unes
les anges de la téléréalité l'île de la
tentation secret story le bachelor jean
djoman célibataire la ville a décrit
brisé aller marseille vs me contre le
reste du monde puisque c'est pas mon
propre ma propre analyse c'est le haut
conseil à l'égalité des femmes et des
hommes qui en 2020 dans son rapport
s'est inquiété de manière très très très
sérieuse sur le cycle de sexisme
véhiculées par ces émissions le csa le
conseil supérieur de nos visuels l'a
également fait à plusieurs reprises dans
les années précédentes dans ses
émissions si vous les regardez et bien
très souvent les femmes sont très
sexualisée peu vêtues à peu importe le
moment de la journée où elles sont
filmées face en face d'elles elles ont
des hommes très viriliser peu vêtues
également comme si on était dans un film
pornographique ou érotiques les les
discussions en plus tourner très souvent
autour de leur vie sexuelle ou
sentimental les convois pas forcément
d'actes sexuels filmé mais ils sont très
souvent su gérer voire on a des caméras
qui finit dans le noir on sait pas ce
qu'il fait allusion le suppose et tout
ça pour vous dire que le lien que la
prostitution c'est
qu'est qui a pu être fait par deux
journalistes qui ont réalisé un
documentaire très intéressant sur la
prostitution
monsieur claude ardid et madame nadia
jubeir dans le monde en face jeunesse à
vendre qui a été diffusé sur france 5 en
2018 ou lorsqu'il vous expliquer leur
travail sur la conception de ce
documentaire il disait que pour eux il y
avait un lien évident entre l'émergence
de la prostitution de mineure au début
de l'année 2010 et leur valeur de
diffusion de cette émission télé réalité
qui correspond au début de l'année 2010
et effectivement dans mes dossiers
judiciaires dans les auditions des
jeunes filles que par cas des mineurs
2013 parfois les jeunes filles vont dire
en audition mais moi mon objectif c'est
de devenir une star de la télé réalité
avoir la même apparence physique que ces
jeunes femmes gagner beaucoup d'argent
rapidement dans l'émission zone
interdite intitulé à 15 ans ma fille se
prostituent diffusée sur m6 en septembre
2020 une des jeunes filles interrogées
le disait très clairement devant la
caméra que c'était son objectif or ces
stars de la télé-réalité voulais
retrouver sur les réseaux sociaux
instagram tik tok snam chat et autres
qui sont également des canaux vous le
savez qu'ils diffusent une image très
stéréotypé et sexualité de la femme
comme je viens l'évoqué tulle à
l'évoquer j'arrive au deuxième temps de
mon intervention sur la question de
savoir pour répondre à votre question le
président de savoir si la pornographie
en ligne mène à la prostitution
des mineurs en ligne également
dans un premier temps j'aimerais vous
dire que bien on les intervenants
précédents ont fait le lien très claire
entre l'industrie pornographique et
l'activité prostitutionnelle je serai
également de références littéraires et
cinématographiques celle de du livre de
robin d'angelo que vous avez déjà
entendu
qui à la lecture montre l'extrême
porosité entre ces deux mondes et les
profits des jeunes filles qui suit sont
des jeunes filles extrêmement
vulnérables et souvent de très jeunes
majeurs une autre série enfin une série
télévisée américaine diffusée entre 2017
et 2019 sur atvo
appelé en anglais the do sul à 42e en
français qui retrace la naissance de
l'industrie pornographique au début des
années 70 à new york et on voit que les
jeunes femmes prostituées dans la rue
bascule ensuite dans l'univers
pornographiques
salissant donc de répondre très
clairement la question qui mettait qui
était posée
ça a été dit il ya des enjeux juridiques
sur cette question à mon sens lorsqu'on
regarde les défis la définition la cour
de cassation qui vous a été rappelé
l'exigence d'un contact physique à mon
sens fait échec à
la caractérisation d'une infraction en
termes de prostitution d'un lorsqu'un
mineur ou une mineure fait un show
sexuelle par exemple dire sa caméra
contre une rémunération
est en train c'est en termes de
l'interprétation des lois pénales
l'interprétation lé strict pour autant
il ya effectivement un débat puisque
cette jurisprudence cette définition
n'est pas posée par la loi c'est la
jurisprudence donc elle peut toujours
être renversé mais effectivement en
termes de sécurité juridique elle y
aurait une nécessité à ce que cette
définition soit posée par le législateur
pour que le clairement laquelle le débat
soit tranché la définition de la juriste
de la cour de cassation elle est
ancienne ça fait quasiment depuis 34 30
40 ans qu'elle n'a pas bougé cette
exigence de contact physique de
rémunération en vue de la satisfaction
d'un besoin sexuelle d'autrui la société
a changé internet est arrivé les
smartphones et il a évoqué d'où la
question qui se pose effectivement
aujourd'hui
pour autant
au-delà du débat juridique ainsi posé la
question de la réalité de ces affaires
de prostitution virtuelle dans ma
pratique depuis donc en quatre ans je
n'ai quasiment jamais eu affaire à ce
type de situation de prostitution en
ligne via les plates-formes en isan
minimes et autres
tout d'abord pas besoin de passer par
ces plateformes
spécialisées il suffit d'échanger par
sms envoyé d envoyer des images ou des
vidéos dénudées par parme et ça joue sur
what's app ou facebook ou que sais-je
contre avec une rémunération qui vient
par la suite donc pas besoin d'avoir des
sites spécialisés ça c'est ça c'est la
première remarque je ferais est par
ailleurs
les activités qui est extrêmement cacher
tout se passe dans un huis clos
lorsqu'une jeune fille ou d'un garçon
sait que expose ses bars des parties
sexuelles de son corps il va pas le
faire devant ses parents bien évidemment
encore moins devant ses amis ça se passe
dans sa chambre dans une salle de bain
dans un lieu clos donc c'est invisible
et al'inverse de la prostitution de que
je connais la pression classique où il a
un
mineur va très souvent être en fugue ou
à minima hors de son domicile il va
revenir parfois dénutri violentée en
abyme est en tout cas physiquement
demeure très clair avec des objets de
valeur donc là la question va vite être
identifié à l'invers de cette
prostitution confins ce qu'on pourrait
qualifier éventuellement de prostitution
virtuel est extrêmement invisible pour
autant je vais vous montrer enfin par
une affaire que j'ai que j'ai traité
sur une situation qu'on pourrait
qualifier de prostitution et virtuels
donc c'est une adolescente de 16 ans qui
se confie un membre du personnel
éducatif parce qu'elle est à 10 est
victime de harcèlement scolaire de la
part des élèves qui prétendent qu'ils
prétendent qu'elles se livrent à des
actes sexuels donc elle va expliquer
qu'elle correspond qu'elle écrirait d
homme qu'elle ne connaît pas et qui
accueille l envoi qui l envoie et reçoit
des photos dénudées en échange de ces
photos érotiques elle reçoit divers
cadeaux abonnement à des chaînes
payantes livres et les vêtements donc
lorsque les policiers vont l'entendre
pour savoir pour eux pour savoir ce
qu'il en est vraiment et puis identifier
les éventuels
auteurs de ces achats de photos de
vidéos elle va confirmer que c'est
effectivement le cas qu'elle l'a fait
mais qu'elle a arrêté depuis qu'elle a
un petit ami et on n'aura pas accès à
son téléphone
il y aura alors toutes effacées entre
qu'on aura plus d'éléments pour remonter
sur d'éventuels clients aux
investigations
et la question je vous dis que se pose
toujours cette question d'appeler du
contact physique sa mère va expliquer de
manière très claire qu'elle n'avait pas
conscience que sa fille était aussi
naïve et inconsciente et elle pensait
qualité c'était une jeune fille à mature
elle avait été alertée quand sa fille
l'a demandé d'acheter des vêtements
assez ayant un caractère assez sexuée ce
qu'il avait un peu inquiété mais elle
n'a pas elle n'a pas cherché au delà
donc voilà c'est l'une des seules à
faire que gilles va traiter pour autant
le sentiment que j'ai pu avoir des échos
jamais de signalements concret de
garçons
qui se livrent à des actes sexuels film
est donc soit des du coup on serait sûr
des shows sexuelle par ces garçons ou
des images envoyées ou des vidéos
envoyées à différents individus
et ça c'est je pense c'est vraiment une
réalité puisque la prostitution
masculine et encore plus des adolescents
des garçons est un tabou très très très
très fort une guerre la question de
l'homosexualité qui vient se greffer à
tout ça mais pour autant je suis certain
que c'est une réalité mais qui est très
peu très peu signalé à la justice et
même de manière générale aux différentes
institutions qui sont en lien avec avec
des mineurs
par ailleurs pas besoin d'un nouveau pas
besoin d'aller sur des sites spécialisés
1 pour faire proposer ses services il ya
des sites très classique qui le propose
également en guise de conclusion sur sur
cette question j'évoquerai deux éléments
dont un a déjà été piqué par les
intervenants précédents c'est la
définition de la prostitution
effectivement proposés dans le rapport
de manière générale champrenault
effectivement la dimension virtuelle est
intégré dans cette définition proposée
est l'autre élément qui a également été
évoqué c'est le délit de sexe torsion à
l'article 227-24 et 2 issu de la loi du
21 avril 2021 qui incrimine depuis cette
date le fait pour un adulte d'inciter un
mineur à se livrer à des pratiques
sexuelles sur internet donc vous avez à
travers cet article notamment et en plus
des infractions pédopornographiques
classique différents outils pour
poursuivre
l'exposition sexuel de mineurs en ligne
je vous remercie de votre attention
merci beaucoup pour cette précision qui
nous a été apportée sur tous ces
thématiques je vais tout de suite passé
la parole à ma voisine rapporteur
laurence cohen qui il souhaite vous
interroger
suite à vos quatre interventions
mesdames et messieurs
porter merci madame la présidente
et merci mesdames et messieurs pour pour
vos propos introductif qui ont éclairé
effectivement la mission qui est la
nôtre et en même temps on est on est
face à
des commandes y en a un peu l'impression
d'être au pied d'une montagne un
français infranchissable au fur et à
mesure qu'on avance dans notre dans
notre dans notre rapport
est que l'on à des auditions qui sont
extrêmement diverse et plurielle
moi j'aimerais peut-être dans c'est pas
tant des questions mais ce sont des
réflexions et avoir un échange avec vous
peut-être un peu plus poussé que les
éléments que vous nous avez apporté
parce que ça ça me m'interroge
évidemment c'est que nous sommes me
semble-t-il face à des paradoxes c'est à
dire à la fois une société au niveau
national comme mondial qui prend
conscience
de jeu le dire comme ça du système
patriarcal qui qui
renvoie à une image de la femme et de
l'homme d'ailleurs qui est extrêmement
stéréotypé et et qui a servi les femmes
pour aller vite et donc cette prise de
conscience de la de la société avec tout
ce qui s'est passé autour de mitu des
paroles qui de plus en plus se font
entendre permettant aux femmes de
montrer qu'elles ne sont pas seules
qu'elles ne sont pas isolés et qui a
besoin de s'unir pour gagner une société
d'égalité et en même temps face à donc à
7 de conscience à cette volonté de
gagner cette égalité dans tous les
domaines
ça a toujours existé au niveau des
militantes et des militants féministes
mais disons que là c'est beaucoup plus
partagée face à ça on a paradoxalement
donc cette
toujours ce cette instrumentalisation du
corps des femmes qui reste une
marchandise est qui qui du coup utilise
j'allais dire d'autres canaux autres cas
des canaux qui sont beaucoup plus
moderne et qui nous échappe c'est à dire
tout ce qui passe par internet etc et
qui touche en fait là pour le coup des
publics extrêmement jeunes et on a en
même temps donc on a on a le sentiment
qu'il ya vraiment un besoin
de contrebalancer donc ces images cette
banalisation de cette marchandisation
des corps en ayant un rôle éducatif
au niveau de l'école mais quand je dis
l'école en fait moi c'est vraiment de la
crèche à l'université je sais pas et ça
ça manque terriblement donc
là je trouve qu'il ya une responsabilité
collective
qui qui est flagrant
la deuxième chose peut-être qu'il se
rapporte plus
de manière plus précise un autre un
autre rapport c'est qu'effectivement
vous avez toutes et tous fait un lien
entre le la prostitution et la
pornographie y compris monsieur en
disant que vous vous voyez nettement une
augmentation de 2,2 delà de la
prostitution face à une diffusion on va
dire de la pornographie mais c'est ce
lien là qui est extrêmement compliqué à
mon avis à mettre en évidence pour nous
parce que suivant les auditions que nous
avons eues quel que soit notre
conviction intime elles ont été parfois
malmenée contrebalancés par des propos
qui disait mais non mais non c'est pas
du tout comme ça et c'est à titre alors
on a l'habitude parce que c'est aussi ce
qu'on aurait tort qu au niveau de la de
la prostitution voilà mais comment est
ce qu'on arrive vraiment à établir une
démonstration un lien c'est c'est ma
deuxième réflexion est ma troisième
réflexion c'est que j'ai effectivement
le sentiment vous écoutant qu'il ya un
angle mort on va dire au niveau de la
justice
et au niveau de ce qui peut être
aussi bien au niveau des définitions
qu'au niveau des sanctions en réalité
donc comment est ce qu'on arrive parce
que quand madame arrighi dit à un moment
donné et la balle est dans le camp des
législateurs c'est vrai mais la balle
est dans le camp des législateurs packer
l'est aussi mais dites vous de haut
niveau de la justice et comment
justement on arrive à concilier tout ça
parce que nous nous dirigeons nous
rétorque aussi pas mal que voilà si on
veut interdire c'est parce qu'on est
moralisateur et cetera que ont brimé les
libertés notamment des adultes qui
finalement deux adultes trois adultes
consentants enfin je sais pas des
adultes je vais pas donner de chez qu'on
s'entend bien le droit de faire ce
qu'ils veulent donc voilà c'est 3 à
trois réflexions qui sont pas tant des
questions mais qui sont plutôt à essayer
de donner des éléments qui nous
permettent peut-être d'étoffer notre
rapport pour le rendre beaucoup plus
solide dans les recommandations qu'on
peut qu'on pourra faire au final
merci beaucoup chers collègues je vais
peut-être passer tout de suite la parole
alors darcos et puis ceux qui voudront
réagir aux réflexions de la rapporteure
laurence cohen et à la question ou
réflexion de notre collègue laure darcos
se manifesteront au près nos invités du
jour merci même chers collègues merci
présidente merci à vos témoignages
bien évidemment en tant que père de
famille c'est ça fait froid dans le dos
et je veux dire que
on avait déjà entendu mais c'est
toujours très compliqué je poursuis
appelé les réflexions de ma collègue
laurence cohen d'abord premièrement je
pense qu'alors je suis la commission de
la culture et je pense que vous avez dit
monsieur sur les émissions de télé
réalité on en a souvent tourné autour du
pot je pense que les traits de notre
devoir ou vous même mais de pouvoir
saisir l'art comme sur sur un sujet
comme celui là leur montrer en effet à
quel point
ces émissions déjà son dégradante pour
l'image de la femme mais on puisse par
vos témoignages
qu'ils puissent mesurer à quel point ça
peut avoir une incidence sur
sur leur sexualité et sur cette cette
prostitution mois sur pour revenir
également sur ce qu'elle dit laurence
sur les moines de justice je j'ai des
centres éducatifs fermés chez moi et
j'avais pu assister à un témoignage d'un
jeune qui y étaient pour viol en réunion
et
qu'a posé une question absolument
incroyable super fientes au juge qui a
dit mais en fait je veux bien faire je
sais que j'ai fait quelque chose de mal
mais je veux savoir en fait à partir de
combien est-ce que c'est interdit
c'était pas donc le fait du viol c'était
de savoir à partir de combien de
camarades
je crois qu'ils avaient été à 8 ou 10
sur cette pauvre jeune fille à partir de
combien en fait ça devient
illégal quoi c'était pour montrer à quel
point ce jeune homme était totalement en
dehors des clous de
des règles de la morale enfin de tous
enfin c'était de perdre tous ses repères
est ce qu'il ya en effet une possibilité
alors peut-être que les centres
éducatifs fermés pour des mineurs dans
ce cas c'était le cas un jeune homme qui
avait 15 16 ans 1 est ce que c'est un
lieu qui se prête à
à une reprise en main de ces deux de ces
de ces jeunes avec peut-être
des des sessions j'imagine très précises
pour leur faire comprendre pourquoi bien
sûr pourquoi c'est mal et et montrer la
gravité de leurs actes ou est-ce qu'en
effet il ya d'autres centres où on
puisse prendre en main ces jeunes avant
qu'ils ne tombent véritablement dans le
crime
et la prison
d'adultes ou malheureusement ils vont
être sûrement dans un engrenage qui ira
encore plus loin voilà à quel moment
est-ce qu'on peut même pour le violeur
ou en tout cas ces personnes qui ont ces
jeunes qui vont faire prêter se prêter à
ces à ces chantages sordide auprès de
deux jeunes filles comment est-ce que
l'éducation nationale est un bon et est
un bon
un bon canal ou est-ce que c'est pas
déjà allé un peu plus loin
vis-à-vis d'autres instruments qu'est la
justice entre ses mains on la pardonnez
moi d'être un peu confuse mais
merci chers collègues pour cette
question l'éducation nationale a des
obligations mais on a parlé tout à
l'heure de l'application de la loi pour
la loi prosteel abolitionniste de la
prostitution il existe aussi dans la loi
des obligations en termes d'éducation à
la sexualité
l'application de la loi et à c est assez
disparates voire
en général inexistante voilà donc je
vais laisser jouer vous laisser vous
organiser pour répondre à ces deux
interventions d'une collègue lens
laurence klein et laure darcos madame
elisabeth moiron projet pas je vais voir
pardon vous laisser complété mais j'ai
juste je voudrais rebondir sur ce qui a
été dit mais je crois que la loi c'est
bien sûr c'est extrêmement important
mais les magistrats ils sont ils sont là
pour appliquer pour mettre en oeuvre
cette loi donc voilà ce que je pense pas
que ce soit les premiers lésés ils sont
pas en tête de gondole conditions plutôt
c'est la fin ils sont plutôt à la fin
d'un parcours c'est la reconnaissance la
fraction la condamnation que ça donc il
faut prendre le problème bhl indien bien
plus en amont et il faut en faire une
tous tout ce dont on a parlé il faut en
faire c'est à dire en fait tout ce qu'on
a dit me somme était très technique par
mouvements etc mais en fait c'est la
marchandisation des corps s'est tous et
qu'accorder pas le marché encore se
respecte on sort et c'est le respect
c'est la dignité humaine pour ça c'est
ça c'est le trop comme un bon à partir
de là il faut une volonté politique
il faut que ce soit une politique
prioritaire parce que ce qui marche bien
c'est justement c'est la prise de
conscience de la société et on n'en fait
pas assez et je le sais pour la
prostitution quand elle retrouve
finalement n'est ce pas là la seule
campagne qu'on a fait sa production
parce qu'il y avait le
comment s'appelait déjà l'europe la
bâche de foot européen je sais plus
comme ça ça elles n'ont en 2016 c'était
le rôle non c'était chez plus comment ça
s'appelle un bon passons quand il ya eu
quand il ya eu le football fait plus
peur c'est un nom mais voilà donc cette
heure 2016 on avait fait des petits des
pistes oui campagne où il y avait des
flashs notamment sur internet etc ou en
dix ans les causes par avant d'enfin là
on avait fait des messages de prévention
il faut avertir on sait que dans tout
par exemple qu'à chaque fois qu'il ya
des manifestations publiques très
importantes comme bientôt on va voir les
jeux olympiques voilà un et on sait que
ces manifestations la elle somme et ses
os x 10 par devin par 30% tout ce qui
est la prostitution les offres de de
prostitution etc donc c'est si on fait
pas ça on n'arrivera jamais à l'or et
donc c'est de sensibilisation essentiel
des messages envoyés régulièrement aussi
des messages qui sont des messages de
prévention peut dire attention voilà on
essaie de réduire les risques si je puis
dire d'exploitation de toutes les
personnes qui sont dans notre société et
surtout les femmes il faut absolument
les femmes et les enfants les prévenir
de ce point de vue là et puis il est
évident que l'éducation nationale a un
rôle absolument essentiel
simplement là vous l'avez soulevée mais
la loi de 2016 a prévu que dans tous les
programmes il y aura des vraiment fait
genre des cours pour expliquer des
conférences pour expliquer justement
tout le danger c'est marqué dans la loi
marchandisation des corps s'est dit
voilà moi dans mon plan dans le plan de
la mi prof le premier et le second plan
d'action de lutte contre la traite
d'êtres humains on a deux mesures on
demande à l'éducation nationale qui
mette dans les programmes justement une
alerte alors que sur l'exploitation
sexuelle autres formes d'exploitation
d'ailleurs pas seulement l'état pourquoi
je ne sais pas mais il semblerait que ce
soit pas vraiment mis en oeuvre je suis
pas les regarder mais metz autour de
vous faites atteste demander si vous
avez des enfants
s'ils ont entendu parler aux jeunes
voilà bon donc c'est là je pense qu'il
ya vraiment c'est là où il faut faire
quelque chose d'ailleurs on voit bien
c'est que quand même côté eu cette
affaire cette affaire horrible de ces
malheureuses qui ont tourné ce film et
que tu as des conditions atroces elles
ont été torturées je marque c'est
horrible alors là la sacu les
consciences s'éveillent alors il faut
les faits faux faut les aider à
s'éveiller il faut pas attendre quand
même ton temps des catastrophes
s'achever le rapprochement puisque
j'étais à bruxelles eh ben on s'est
rendu compte d'une chose aussi c'est
qu'il a fallu la guerre en ukraine et
les risques d'exploitation des matériaux
sexuels notamment des jeunes
ukrainiennes pour que tout à coup on se
met à en parler parce que apparemment de
la traite des êtres humains
d'exploitation non pas le traître et là
on n'arrête pas on a des demandes
d'interviews des vins d'espagne virton
petite urne est vraiment dedans quoi
donc voyez donc il faut que toujours des
éléments très grave pour qu'on prenne
connaissance de conscience de la chose
qui est déjà bien parce que au moins ya
une prise de conscience et les gens ne
peuvent pas à prouver ça mais vous aussi
communiqué vous avez rappelé le tout ces
toutous tous ces jeunes qui se
prostituent moi je vois bien une chose
mais tout ça c'est une question de
priorité pour une politique vraiment
parce que on doit alerter mais ça je
sais qu'on a commencé à le faire mais ce
sont aussi des des mesures qui sont
prévus dans le plan de lutte contre la
prostitution il faut il faut en parler
il faut faire des campagnes il faut
mobiliser il faut en faire une pause
vraiment une cause prioritaire voilà
c'est mon sentiment
est ce que l'un des intervenants voulait
compléter parce que c'était plutôt des
remarques qui ont été faites donc y
avait pas de forcément de questions s'il
n'y a pas d'autres questions j'avais
peut-être une question pour monsieur
baldo par rapport aux à la montée des
signalements que vous avez fait un
parallèle entre les signalements et
finalement la situation aussi sur la
toile et lorsque vous avez dit il ya 365
milles signalement par an on sait qu' il
y a ça pourrait paraître énorme en
réalité ce chiffre sauf que je les dis
dans mon propos liminaire il y a dix
neuf 19 millions de vues uniques par
mois donc en réalité est ce que vous
êtes finalement équipés pour monter en
puissance parce qu'on le voit bien les
images sont de plus en plus barbare de
plus en plus voilà les sites où on tend
monde pour attirer montant en violence
mais entend barbarie montrent aussi
finalement ce sont de moins en moins
conforme est certain par rapport à la
loi donc est ce que vous êtes
cap est équipé en termes de ressources
humaines en termes de moyens pour faire
face à cette cette montée en puissance
et cette industrie florissante
merci alors à l'heure actuelle je dirais
oui
néanmoins nous avons tous conscience au
sein de l'office auquel nous appartenons
que
la montée en puissance comme vous l'avez
dit mal la présidente est inéluctable et
que c'est une course à l'échalote en
réalité il nous faudra perpétuellement à
augmenter nos moyens pour
pouvoir faire face à l'instant t je
dirais que nos ressources sont
convenables
peut-être que dans deux ans je ne
pourrais pas tenir ce discours ou
peut-être même avant ne pourrais-je plus
mais pour l'instant oui nous avons été
redimensionné l'année dernière justement
au moment où nous a demandé de passer en
h24 cet homme je dis
donc les ressources sont là une
ressource somme a eu un gros effort fait
par le par le gouvernement pour nous
mettre des moyens
quid de l'avenir je ne sais pas je ne
peux pas chiffré les choses mais je suis
je puis vous assurer avec certitude
qu'il faudra perpétuellement augmenter
la surface de fabre c'est certain
merci pour cette réponse c'est vrai que
le sénat s'est emparé de ce sujet en
début d'année en réalité peu s'étaient
emparés du sujet donc j'ai le mythe ou
de la pornographie n'a pas encore eu
lieu et si il devait avoir lieu
probablement que vous devriez
adapter les moyens pour y répondre
clairement écoutez ya un pardon mais
cette installation réplique aux
remarques en fait par les sénatrices
question du lien entrepreneurs gravier
prostitution vous demander des éléments
concrets pour votre rapport à mon sens
vous les avez les études en terme par
exemple d' usage de téléphone portable
et les adolescents enfin c'est des
choses qui sont qui commence à être
vastement étudie en france et à
l'étranger de manière générale vous avez
des études françaises dans cette
question là sur le rapport qu'on nous a
volé son téléphone portable cet endroit
qui est devenu comme un fin pour des
jeunes qui ont des troubles de
l'attachement notamment les jeunes qu'on
va retrouver dans l'est qui vont être
victimes de faits sexuels notamment de
proxénétisme peut-être un portable c'est
un enjeu essentiel est un exemple très
concret très concret fin dans le film
polisse ou des scènes assez dramatique
c'est cette jeune fille qui dit qu'elle
a fait une fellation pour récupérer son
téléphone portable ce que je retrouve
très souvent dans mes dossiers les
policiers rigole en fait en face parce
qu'ils sont sidérés c'est tellement
tellement incroyable mais c'est une
réalité cette fellation contrainte
téléphone portable pour récupérer son
téléphone montre à quel point il ya un
lien très fort de ces jeunes avec leurs
portables et leurs portables on l'a dit
avec tout ce qui à tous les accès qui
sont dessus sur la consommation du des
delà de la pornographie par des
adolescents vous avez des éléments j'ai
cité manager elle qui a beaucoup et une
description en france mais à l'étranger
c'est également étudié comme comme comme
thématique avec des ombres des études
des études quantitatives manager dans un
dans un livre en l'occurrence
dirigé qu'odile dirigé par madame lavaud
legendre et madame g elle a produit deux
chapitres de ce livre elle part d'une
étude faite en normandie avec des
chiffres très précis sur une population
de lycéens et lycéennes professionnel
avec la consommation de pornographie de
c'est en tout cas l'accès à la
pornographie de ces jeunes mais c'est un
exemple parmi tant d'autres je pense que
vous avez beaucoup de choses en réalité
qui sont accessibles il faut
effectivement les rassembler cendre au
travail de recherche et d analyse j'en
ai bien joué de la conscience mais vous
avez des chiffres les chiffres sont là à
mon sens et et ils sont et sont connus
tant sur la scène française qu
internationale sur la question de la
justice ben
c'est pas pour être ta came j'ai envie
de vous dire que votre commission est né
parce que la justice a répondu à l
enquête des gendarmes
et parce que ça a été rendu public donc
du coup la justice ne fait pas rien à
mon sens
elle a permis à une réaction
elle a permis à la réaction de votre
commission qui question à cette question
de la pornographie dans nos sociétés et
dernière observation peut être madame la
sénatrice qui est derrière moi sur la
question demain qu'est ce qu'on fait
avant la prison avant le centre éducatif
fermé
on l'a dit c'est effectivement c'est
l'éducation qu'elle soit primaire par
les parents ou secondaire par l'école
mais malheureusement laissé 2
ces deux parties la de l'éducation enfin
ses deux acteurs principaux que sont les
parents et l'école sont défaillants de
manière volontaire ou involontaire sur
cette question de la sexualité fins et
c'est très rare en général que les qu'on
parle de sexualité qui sépare encore
aujourd'hui et est allé à l'école voilà
il ya des la rappeler c'est les
obligations qui sont imposés sont
parfois peu respectée et quand il ya des
tentatives gouvernementales
il ya eu des échecs aussi en la matière
je pense vous avez cédé de l'égalité qui
a travaillé sur la question du
consentement notamment donc voilà il ya
des
identifiants des difficultés après il
faut vous les refouler les surmonter
voilà le micro c'est mieux écoutez je
vous remercie sincèrement tous les cas
tu d'avoir participé à cette table ronde
vous avez éclairé à la fois sur la
définition de la prostitution avec sa
propre définition qui semble assez
obsolète au regard des évolutions de la
société et des des outils numériques
vous avez mis en évidence de façon
parfois extrêmement clair la porosité
porosité pardon évidente entre
prostitution et pornographie est
démontré que l'industrie de la
pornographie ne respectait pas cette
définition ce principe constitutionnel
du respect de la dignité humaine
vous avez démontré des similitudes entre
pornographie prostitution entre
producteurs et proxénètes et démontrer
le lien entre progression du porno et
prostitution des mineurs avec la
banalisation des actes et de pratiques
sexuelles vous avez prouvé que
pornographie s'apparentait parfois
finalement de la traite d'êtres humains
et mis en évidence des angles morts de
des politiques publiques c'est une
réalité nous n'avons pas eu à ce stade
aujourd'hui de politiques publiques qui
s'empare de ce sujet et donc il est
important d'apporter des réponses oui la
pornographie n'est pas un sujet mineur
oui la prostitution des mineurs n'est
pas un sujet mineur
nous sommes face à je crois au
au fur et à mesure de ses auditions moi
j'ai l'impression qu'on est face à un
tsunami qui arrive dans termes
d'éducation des jeunes générations donc
il ya urgence à la fois à protéger les
victimes que nous avons auditionné les
victimes de l'industrie pornographique
mais il y à aussi urgence à protéger les
mineurs qui accèdent de manière
involontaire ou volontaire à tous ces
sites donc bien entendu nous allons
poursuivre nos travaux il faut que la
société tout entière ouvre les yeux
c'est à dire que pour pouvoir avancer
pour que la loi évolue pour que la
société
apporte des réponses il faut qu'on
souhaite tous en capacité de regarder ce
tsunami
qui est face à nous et qui déjà le
comprennent et apporte des réponses donc
vraiment je vous remercie sincèrement de
cette participation et des réponses
précises que vous avez pu nous apporter
les sénateurs et sénatrices qui était en
visioconférence je le précise je les
remercie pour leur participation n'avait
pas de question à vous poser je ne
l'aurais pas couper la parole au coupé
le micro belle journée à tous
[Musique]